[Applause]
every time a girl [ __ ] a dude that's
successful or famous she a hoe
and if she gets a job out of it i
support sex work also if there were more
successful famous women we would [ __ ]
them
that's the only reason why we're not
[ __ ] them
you don't think somebody would slide
some dick up barbara corker in
yo let me tell you something
yo if barbara corcoran got a three
bedroom for your boy in dumbo
my girl gonna be about that [ __ ] you
better put on a condom get us his condo
i'm not doing this 2300 square feet
barbara corcoran and i can fill up any
square footage you need if you know what
i'm saying
wink wink
yeah y'all yo you got a garage because
i'll park my [ __ ] in your garage
easy money yo easy money that's all i'm
saying
ladies if you listen i know a lot of
women out here no this is important a
lot of women out here feeling
judged because men aren't [ __ ] them
to get ahead in life the problem is
y'all not ahead
y'all busy giving it y'all not ahead we
need y'all to get ahead
yeah okay there's three oprah's
oprah who the other two oprah's judge
judy
oh yeah
[Applause]
like how [ __ ] up is that
the [ __ ] is on zara
that's a [ __ ] well it was a guy but she
divorced him i think she gets half a
czar
you know that's how these women make
billions yeah yeah amazon's wife
mackenzie bezos why what's she doing she
giving most of her we don't care
she gets it wait she does yeah because
she gets she's giving moser money to
charity
she knows she charity yeah she's chair
gets it i mean like
that's how i got my money jeff has given
[ __ ] to nobody ever
you know that's the [ __ ] you know people
say the buck stops with me
not in her case buck keeps bucking yeah
she battles you forward
okay so but that is a real thing if
ladies
you get into these power positions which
is what we want
you get into these power positions right
we would love to [ __ ] you
and take advantage of that power you
already have we would love that
opportunity
it just so happens that
we can't think anything y'all
um the other thing is that girls aren't
gonna [ __ ] down
say what i don't think girls like well
well we had a discussion about that
what girl the assumption was all the way
back in the day
the assumption was always girls don't
[ __ ] down
so the more successful women get the
harder it is for them evolutionary
evolutionary yes but here's the thing
women are [ __ ] up because [ __ ] up
provides security
yes at the end of the day like let's
make like the most biological arguments
right [ __ ] up
this guy is gonna have enough money to
take care of you while you're
incapacitated for nine months while
you're being pregnant
and raise the kids and raising the kids
survive it's it is the smart decision
calling a girl hope for that is is
[ __ ] up but my opinion is [ __ ] up
the biological decision isn't even smart
it's what we're programmed to do and you
know what's interesting is like you
always hear these dudes go like well men
cheat because it's our biology and then
when women [ __ ] successful people
they're like [ __ ]
yeah it's the same biology bro same
biology yeah
so here's the thing we've noticed
that once girls get security
they got the same sexual appetite as us
once girls like guaranteed uh ex bezos
guaranteed x bezos
the side dick she getting right now is
the guy that works on the grounds of her
property oh
yeah that fine ass dude fine ass dude
yeah man package is still getting
delivered jeff
oh and this one's in his prime all right
so the point is when these women end up
getting that security
life security that they don't have to
worry about now their sexual appetite
reflects us
they [ __ ] the closest thing around
they [ __ ] the easiest thing to [ __ ]
guys we don't have standards a lot of
times because he's like yo what is the
easiest thing to take down
what's the monica lewinsky you're there
oh [ __ ] yeah
he could have whatever girl but there's
a cost if bill clinton wants to go and
find some victoria's secret model of
[ __ ]
yeah oh she's going to talk yada yada it
ended up happening anyway but still
and you see this happen so now
we can look at our sexual appetites as a
function of security men we have
security
sometimes men don't have security and
they will [ __ ] for it
madonna's 62 got 25 year old boyfriend
does she not yeah
guaranteed that dude was not secure
guarantee that dude has not come for
money
guaranteed dude did not have a great job
guaranteed dude is living off of her
in some way shape or form i'm much more
embarrassed by that dude than i am if
it's 25 year old girl 62 year old man
ooh going that was going insane
no because that again i'm looking at it
from a biological standpoint of like
dog your whole goal as a man is to
become a provider
so you can be more attractive to other
women if you're [ __ ] for the security
that's like
i'll be honest i find it like
biologically not masculine that's some
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah it's evolutionarily tapping out you
tapping out the game like you're
supposed to provide for yourself
you're the providers what you were born
to do is provide
in an evolutionary sense that's what men
do you provide so you can get
you know the best woman or whatever and
pass on the strongest jeans and you're
just tapping out of that
he might be playing a long game get with
old [ __ ] she dies
you inherit her i think that's [ __ ] now
he's
i think that's i judge that much more
than i judge the girl anna nicole smith
i feel you but i think dudes are playing
girls again it's the same thing keep
that same energy that's biological i get
why a woman does that
that's every species is get the most
attractive mate
and not just attractive physically like
who can provide the best life for me
and my security yes is security bro
so i get biologically anna nicole smith
partic if they didn't have kids maybe
not as much
but if they had kids i'd get it on an
evolutionary level i understand that's
what we're driven to do
a guy's not driven to do that in most
any species
yo you know what
maybe rich dudes find security in gold
diggers
because they know that the girl is
attracted to golds
so all they have to do is to continue
making goals
give them some [ __ ] to dig up exact give
them a [ __ ] to dig and as long as they
can still dig
they will be there they will be loyal
they will be secure
right yeah whereas a dude that is only
good at making gold and not really good
at like building emotional connections
with people might be
insecure about a relationship with a
woman who actually wants an emotional
connection with them
because they might not feel like they're
interesting enough to be loved for just
themselves
so it's easier to have that relationship
okay i make the gold this [ __ ] loves
the gold she's not gonna leave me she's
gonna take care of my kids i feel secure
also evolutionarily i get a guy getting
a girl like that because that's what we
covered
we covet the girl like attractiveness
pretty much across every country from
this is 20 years ago when i was in
college and i really study but like
it's who gives me the best kids what's
like the most the wide hips the
hourglass figure
the big breasts help nourish kids the
wide hips make
childbirth easier that's what we're
attracted to like
she's the gold digging wife that's what
i'm evolutionarily drawn to yo y'all
suck titties
[Laughter]
do y'all do that yeah what yo do y'all
suck it
do you also do you suck it uh not suck
but lick you don't suck too much
do you suck it sound like a pacifier
yo sucking titties is this [ __ ]
maybe he is hungry
yo for real though we gotta talk about
sucking titties bro
you not out there sucking out why do you
not do that
son yeah weird oh hold on y'all never
suck at titty and you get one of your
girls little titty hairs in your mouth
and you'd be sucking extra heart anyway
y'all never do that in floss while you
suck a chick that's too descriptive
i'll never floss on your girl titty hair
you know every once in a while if you're
growing a little titty hair just mine
you